[Music]
thank you all very much and a warm
welcome to this hour that I think he's
going to be hopefully fairly
mind-blowing and at least it's dry and
as Nick was saying relatively warm in
here so I think we're in the right place
for a bit of heavyweight discussion
about the mind's eye as this is entitled
I'm not going to say very much before I
introduce the three of the panelists in
more detail it's worth saying I suppose
that the soul as a concept has been out
of fashion for quite a while now the
question is whether it might be on its
way back and whether it might be a good
thing if it were on its way back Galen
Strawson who is on at my right here is
professor of philosophy at the
University of Reading is the author
among other things of selves an essay in
revisionary metaphysics David Malone has
directed films on science philosophy and
religion for both the BBC and channel 4
we'll forgive him that including
soul-searching voices in my head and on
my left nicholas humphrey who's
theoretical psychologist and whose books
include sold us the inner eye he's also
part of a project to develop an
evidence-based theory of consciousness
evidence-based whatever they think of
next
now if we put aside faith based notions
of the soul can a secular interpretation
help us to make sense of consciousness
well I'm hoping that in the course of
this we'll find out what our panelists
answers are to that and many other
questions and I'm going to give each of
you a maximum I think of four minutes to
set out your theory of this you don't
have to use the whole four minutes but
it would be useful and let's start with
Nicholas Humphrey Nick thanks Ron well
guess the question we were given was
start with us kind of secular
interpretation of the soul help us make
sense of consciousness and I suppose the
question is to make what we mean by
making sense of consciousness I'm a
scientist I'm an evolutionary scientist
in particular and of course what I I
have two main questions about
how does it come into existence in each
of our heads daily what look about the
brain can create consciousness and
second day why did it come into
existence what happened fell back in our
history which actually made
consciousness a good thing to have now
it's in relation to the second part of
this that I think the soul can help I
don't think a soul can help us make
sense of what consciousness is but I
think it can makes and help us make
sense of what consciousness is for or
what it's come to be for in our species
though perhaps not in other animals as a
scientist I have seen it was my job
asking this question to be what I call a
natural historian of consciousness to
just go out there in the world and see
what it's doing for people I don't think
we can study consciousness in the lab or
the armchair for that matter I am an
experimental psychologist initially but
I think actually we need to go out there
and look out there at the uses people
make of consciousness how is it changing
their lives what's it doing for them
what do they think about it and the
answer that comes back from anthropology
from religion from daydreaming from
everything else continually is that our
consciousness is doing many wonderful
things but the one thing people come
back to again and again is it's the
basis for the human soul and the soul
has been transformative in the way we
think about each other and the way we
relate to each other and in fact in the
way we've come to spite the material
world I'll come back to that I think
thanks very much and eminently and well
within our four minutes but it doesn't
mean to say the others get to use more
David Malone let's deal with your sense
of the soul and well I think the word
soul is very useful I think it's a word
which existed before the more modern
self and I think we retain both words
because they point to two different
things two different sets of experiences
the experiences where you feel you did
something where you feel you can report
on how you did it when you work out how
many tiles you need to tile your kitchen
floor you know there's a problem you
know how you're going to do it and you
can report on how you did it it's the
part of you that speaks that's the part
of you that works out your income tax
and you feel it's what you'll do
and you can always tell other people how
you feel you did it but then there are I
think a whole other set of experiences
which don't feel like that where a
thought comes to you you can't report on
ever having really worked it out there
were no steps it just came to you and
you don't know where it came from and
often they're the thoughts that feel
very important and sometimes they're
transformative and I think the word soul
is useful because it reminds us there is
a whole there are a whole set of
experiences which aren't like the ones
that the word self points to and
therefore I think it's worth having both
and I think it's because we have those
sets of experiences that lots of
cultures have a word
very much like soul soul psyche Atman so
it's not something that just popped up
in here why it's it's it's it's been
around for a very long time lots of
human beings and lots of different
cultures and lots of different ages have
reported on it I think it would be a
piece of foolishness to take all of that
into us folk psychology memeber clear
that away while we do some proper
science as it said you've got to start
with people who have the thing that
you're going to investigate and at least
trust them to report on what it is and I
think part of our problem in the West
and I do think there is a problem is
that we have so few words to describe
this thing consciousness that we're
after when the main three we have is
consciousness self and soul and I've
read dozens of books on consciousness
and listen to dozens of area diet people
and half the time I have the distinct
feeling that when they use the word
consciousness that they're actually
meaning slightly different things and so
they're talking past each other the
ancient Greeks had at least four or five
different words which they used to point
toward different aspects of it they
would talk about new psyche frames film
us and I think if we've only got three
and if we threw a one away
because we said it's got some religious
connotations we'd be down to two I mean
we have more
words for mowing the lawn we need all
the words that we can get and I think
the most important thing that the soul
does and it's most of what the religious
definition is and I'd like to I'm not
religious I don't believe in God but we
feel that there are thoughts that come
from outside us that sometimes these
thoughts seemed wiser than us and we
recognize that it's not really from me I
didn't I didn't do it and then when you
talk to someone else they have the same
experience so they in them have this
facility to connect to some place of
wiseness where thoughts come to them
they don't feel like theirs either so I
don't think it's that strange that in
the past people have thought about that
and said well I wonder what it does come
from maybe there's a there's a realm of
wiseness and maybe it's given to me by
an all-seeing God but what I would say
is strip away that and you're still left
with most of the aspects of the
traditional soul wiseness not you come
some somewhere else and I think it's
most important thing about the soul is
it reminds us that a great deal of what
goes on in here isn't you the self is a
johnny-come-lately it's like someone who
moved into a mansion exists in the front
two rooms answers the door every day and
says there's my house I live here has
never been to most of the rooms in the
house what kind of idiot would deny that
there was something going on in the rest
of the house I think the word soul is
very important in reminding us of things
that the jumped-up Germany come like
these self whatever listen to that it's
just me I'd like to own the place
David thank you very much out in there
yeah do you think this room for for this
where the squatters but there's room for
something else in there leave a sigh
don't save it up but I think I'd that
thought in your okay I'll just do so the
question was can a secular
interpretation soul help us to make a
sense of consciousness so I assumed that
a secular interpretation was so supposes
that the flow is just the brain and I
think that's right if we want to talk
about souls at all the soul is just the
mind and the mind is just the brain so
the question is can the brain help us
make sense of conscious muscles but I
don't think we have to make sense of
consciousness it's just there and I
don't see any problem with that fact and
I'll say a little bit about that so what
do we find in the brain we find a lot of
common or garden elements carbon
nitrogen oxygen sodium potassium and so
on and consciousness and when you put
these common or garden elements together
in the incredibly complicated way in
which they are put together in brains
like ours or in the brains of dogs you
get some very complicated
electrochemical processes and these
processes I take it just our
consciousness and they are as
consciousness generally speaking just
what they seem to be so some people say
look we know what carbon oxygen sodium
potassium and so on are when we know the
kinds of reactions they get into with
each other and we now have physical
processes work and it's absolutely plain
that they can't give rise to
consciousness because that's something
completely different so they say
consciousness doesn't really exist or
it's some kind of illusion but that's
just wrong because we know that
consciousness exists we know it with
certainty and we know just what it's
like generally speaking any six-year-old
has a completely correct general idea of
what consciousness is just in heavy so
where are we we know that consciousness
exists we take it this consciousness is
just brain activity what follows what
follows is that physical stuff like
carbon nitrogen oxygen sodium potassium
and so on is much more amazing than we
thought because it has the following
property when you put it together in the
way it put the
and brains you get consciousness exactly
as it is experienced by all of us all
the time so I agree with Russell so this
fact about physical stuff the fact that
if you put it together in a certain way
you get consciousness is easily our best
clue to the ultimate intrinsic nature of
the physical so anyone who thinks
there's a problem with the idea that
physical stuff can be conscious has gone
wrong somewhere
one more so look doesn't physics so
normal faith doesn't physics a there's
problem with consciousness how can
physical stuff becomes answer is no
physics has nothing to say about it's
absolutely nothing and it's important
that this isn't any sort of failure on
the part of physics physics is great at
what it does but it's an increasingly
familiar point but physics with its
numbers and constants and equations only
tells us about structure physics doesn't
tell us about the intrinsic nature of
the thing that has the structure that
physics reveals and whatever it tells us
it doesn't tell us anything that creates
any difficulty with the idea that
consciousness is wholly physical that's
really all I want to say at this point
I'll say this too so Eddington or
something funny happened Eddington
Russell and Whitehead were really clear
about this in the 20s and then the point
son I got lost around smiley 60 and
fluffers started denying the existence
of consciousness or saying it was an
illusion because they thought it was
ruled out by physics or in conflict with
physics well business we need the Pooh
would say was a very big mistake
Galen thank you very much right now
we've got an idea of where everybody
sits at the moment at least in their
initial opening gambits on this question
but let's rule now the debate between
the three of you now into the some of
the areas that this has exposed the
first one I suppose that we might want
to talk about is whether or not these
are simply terms interchangeable terms
that have come from different places for
the same theorem Nick consciousness and
so one has a faith-based origin the
other one has perhaps a more
science-based origin and we're really
talking about this
I'm sure we're not talking about the
same thing how do I actually want to
take issue with some other things which
come before that I mean Galen and his
little lecture started off by saying
that a secular idea of the soul clearly
means the brain
I don't think means that for a moment
perhaps people around here what they
mean by the soul and it's assumed you're
going to give a secular answer in other
words you're not going to relate it to
God or to all the faith of any sort
you're going to start talking about the
spirit which you discover moves you the
kind of thing which which David talked
about you're going to talk about the
what you wake up to every morning as you
open your eyes and no no your sense your
mind gets flooded with sensory
experience with those strange and
wonderful almost magical properties and
so on no mention of the brain there all
these things are what we mean by the
soul and that's what we and it's what we
mean by consciousness - and those are
the issues which we have at some point
to relate to the brain but they aren't
the same thing as the brain and the way
in which the brain creates them isn't a
double step firstly in my view the brain
creates a particular kind of a loser
very a display in our mind which we
interpret as the magical qualities of
sensation on that we build the idea of a
self on that so culture we build the
idea of a soul and I think Society of a
soul is an cultural phenomenon because
so it's not created by any one of our
particular brains it's been created by
our joint brains and our ancestors
brains
so there's there's a lot of other issues
I have around that but on the question
of whether there's nothing to discuss
Galen reminds me of William Empson one
the critic once said he said of other
critics he said critics are of two sorts
those who simply relieve themselves
against the flower of beauty and others
less continent who otherwise scratch it
up and he went on I am I swear must
confess belong to the second second of
these categories unexplained Beauty
arouses an irritation in me and I have
exactly the same response together onyx
just to say consciousness is and so
let's leave it at dark that just
irritates me you know I want to know
more I want to know why it is what how
it comes the matter even if we accept
Galen's
good plan that it's that it conscious is
just inherent and that at which I don't
actually think is the right way to put
it
nonetheless it's different in different
form forms of matter different
combinations of matter our brains when
they're asleep don't seem to have
consciousness in the way they have when
we wake up and so on so the question is
why when matter gets organized in this
way does it produce this astonishing
phenomenon of consciousness that's a
good question and I think a scientific
question Gail it would come back a
little well I think in a way I think
this sounds like you're making the
mistake that I think the people are
making when they think that physics is
in conflict with being a realist about
consciousness that is you say it's not
just the brain but I say it is just the
brain but the brain is everything that
you mentioned is in that is that so
you're dissing your doing that when
people use the phrase the brain they
somehow think that it means the physical
thing that you see funny pictures of
them but the brain means everything that
it is and that includes all the
consciousness and everything that you
qualify as magical and wonderful so the
brain is just more but well I mean
that's it's just the brain but good spec
the question of what is an illusion and
what isn't and whether illusions are not
worth talking about I mean it's the
Queen another is she just part of our
brains um you know the Queen is
something the notion of royalty and all
the panoply which goes with it is
something which has been created out of
certain or and around a certain figure
who exists as another plain human being
in other terms we invest it with a whole
lot of properties or how were the whole
lot of properties and she becomes that
very thing she becomes a queen I think
our souls become souls by virtue of what
we invest them with because of the
payoff attract we get from doing just
that and to say you know it that it's an
illusion and therefore that would be to
diminish it it's not I think the right
approach at all it's a wonderful
illusion the royalty is a wonderful
illusion the soul is a wonderful
illusion ben-hur when you see it on the
screen is wonderful illusion all these
things matter to us a contrast
and they they change the way we live our
lives so let's stop talk about something
being just an illusion as if that was
someone Oh something we have to avoid I
want to bring David in and you clearly
do see a distinction between
consciousness and soul that they are in
helpful ways of describing two different
things can you just elaborate a bit on
what you think those two different
things are and and why they exist in
that way yes I mean I think and however
one wants to describe it losing or not I
think it's a patent truth that we're
conscious I have it if you don't you
just try it it's great and I eat from an
evolutionary point of view and that's my
only claim to the scientific background
I there is evolution he clearly created
consciousness it at some point it came
into being it wasn't here when we had
rocks only rocks and now we have it and
I think however it's though you could
say that consciousness just it just is
and it is of a these and senses it's
just a fact but how do we experience it
and do we experience it always in the
same way and I think the soul what we
now might mean by the word soul in a
secular sense is the way perhaps that
consciousness was and still is in us
before the more modern self came along
what I mean to say is this the the sense
of herself who steps back from from who
he is and said oh I wonder if I feel
comfortable being up here with all these
variable gusts people and then has a
moment of panic think god don't stop
getting worried about that you lose the
track of what you're going to say that
sort of self which can step back and
back and back I take that to be the
modern self but I think there was
possibly creatures who could think could
plan could fornicate could be loving
could betray each other before there's
any sign in the archaeological record
that they saw themselves before the
first representation of any kind of
human being any art so whether you say
came the sir modern self came a hundred
thousand years ago when Homo sapiens
came wrong with
two thousand years ago with the first
sign of representational heart a
handprint on war there were creatures
who existed before that who are
conscious and I think that organization
is still in us and maybe that's what the
word soul is pointing to and then
something new came along this
johnny-come-lately the self and I think
it's useful that we have that word I
think our problem is we need quite a
number more why do we think that this
most extraordinary thing that the
universe is produced can be dealt with
with two or three paltry words no wonder
we're not making any sense out of it
when did when did this Johnny that come
lately arrived hey not chatting with
that one I don't know I let's say and
someone like Harold Bloom will say the
modern self came along with Shakespeare
some other people say the ancient Greeks
had it I I'm agnostic what I'm saying is
that I I don't think that dogs have that
kind I don't think they're only dogs who
sit around thinking I'm a cat trapped in
a dog's body I know but they're
conscious so he came around some time
before I think that the yes in the sense
that a formulation of consciousness a
way that consciousness existed and
thought was around before the MOT the
self and because evolution doesn't throw
things away I would say the chances are
it's still here that creature which is
not you sir is in your brain and he's
thinking the thoughts and has the habits
of mind that it had a hundred thousand
or a million years ago David I think
well agreeing about a lot but actually
I'd put the the would put there of the
order the other way around
yeah and partly because I would look at
child development and ask what occurs in
the development of a child in the order
in which these are self conceptions
begin to emerge and it seems to me that
the soul is a relatively light one
actually that a little girl of
of three or four years old already has
herself will use the word I and so on um
and even begin to refer to other people
as I and think are they like me in the
rest of it but the soul ISM is a much
grander idea than that for me at least
the soul and the value it came to have
in the history of our species arose when
on top of this conception of self
culture imposed a whole lot of super
ordinate ideas like for example the idea
of immortality of being able to perhaps
reincarnation and a whole lot of other
extraordinary important ideas to our
sense of who we are and how we relate to
the world which are not just
metaphysical or religious baggage you've
turned out to know quite much from
tremendously importance in giving us the
ambitions to live the lives we do and to
dare live the lives we do and to have
the hopes for our children that we do so
I think that that idea of a soul is a
rather grander one in my sense and and
came lately when I come to this back to
this question of an illusion I think
it's something we need to sort out um
and Galen will know this story Elizabeth
Anscombe told it about Vikram Stein who
turned to her and said Elizabeth what
people everywhere think that the Sun
goes round the earth and she said well I
suppose it's because it looks like that
and he said ah what would it look like
if it was the other way around and the
earth went around the Sun I mean um and
the answer is it would look exactly the
same um you can't tell from what's
coming well it looks like whether it's
allusion or not because if it's an
illusion it's doing the job of replacing
the reality which would have been the
yeah I am I am bothered by this word
illusion because it seems to me
consciousness can't be an illusion and
it just is clear that it really exists
and it really is pretty much what you
think it is and there's actually the
point is suppose you tried to imagine
that consciousness was an illusion well
then they'd have to be that the process
which was its seeming that there was an
illusion of consciousness but that
process we're already
be consciousness so it's actually
provably impossible for consciousness to
be in illusion in any sense at all well
has a good line in things which are
provably impossible
Vanessa like you can't have free will
because it's always got to get going so
let's give another case so you think
you're seeing let's say a great big
expansive red and someone says no that's
really in the illusion but then what is
the state that consists in your having
the illusion of seeing a great big
expensive red that has already got to
have the qualitative character of
redness no because they represent all
representations do not have to have the
character of conscious representations
oh actually I agree with that but
there's color when they represent
something as having some very remarkable
apparently almost emergent properties
which require a sensation appear to most
of us to have I mean for example they
have properties which really don't seem
to fit with being physical phenomena for
one particular one with psychologists or
was concentrated on is here is the
apparent fact that the subjective moment
lasts more than a physical instant I
mean of course physical time displaying
postures without in a let-up and
relentless movement from one instant to
another but we don't experience a world
like that and we don't experience pains
and colors and smells and things like
that they seem to hang on a little the
subjective moment lasts for longer than
the physical instant know this you can
easily show these actually you know it's
a calm it's a nonsensical idea if we try
and say well this is a physical
phenomenon which is being represented as
extended time but nonetheless it's an
illusion which seems to suit us all
pretty well we like being living in what
I've called the thick moment of
consciousness and I've drawn the analogy
between that and other visual illusions
and let's use that word again where for
example you all be very familiar with
this one the so-called impossible
triangle which you can look at a
triangle made in fact a real object made
of wood which appears to you to be
organized so that in fact it's
impossible to or joints don't add up to
each other well you can make something
which actually has those properties to
you when seen from one that take
to the point of view it's an illusion
it's an illusion you you know it's an
illusion
you can't rid yourself of it that's just
how it looks to you um and I think that
many of the qualities for consciousness
are it's in the sin that we from our
perspective are experiencing something
which is in fact a piece of theater in
our brain which has minor cartons has
been designed to give us the sense of
living in the in the midst of a piece of
magical theater because that makes us
very special kinds of creatures we are
the audience to this mystery and being
being such you know it lifts us outside
ordinary matter and outside ordinary
animality but you're saying that it has
value in itself because it's therefore
changed our relationship with other
human beings
well as long as we know we have a soul
then others have a soul as well
therefore we have to treat this in a
dance that I think becomes a very
important part of once we've yes once
we've identified this extraordinary
phenomenon in our own case then we both
as a matter of generosity but soon as a
matter of just it ceases an only way to
deal with all the people assume that
they as we are equally this centres of
phenomenal consciousness that every one
of them has going on within them
something quite as magical quite quite
as private quite as mysterious but quite
as significant as we have going on
inside us now that understanding of what
it is to be another person is a
remarkable thing chimpanzees don't think
about other chimpanzees like that let
alone dogs or rats think about other
members of our species we think of human
beings as having souls and that gives
them the quality of what we've June
averse to regard as personhood that has
been again a very significant event in
the history of our species once we we we
made that move and I've said
specifically that allowed us to enter a
new ecological niche and I call that
soul and the soul that soul Mitch we're
about halfway through I just want to
pause at this point just take a quick
straw poll of the audience and who here
believes in the idea religious or not
religious of the soul
anyone doesn't mm interesting
I don't know how many don't knows that
leaves but Galen who you feeling does
that make you feel it yeah but a little
more defensive about your position what
is what is my position actually I don't
see I can't imagine why it would would
because I've got so many problems with
the ways things are being put I can't
possibly say them all but you know you
have johnny-come-lately living in the
front two rooms but and you say that's
the self and the foal is in the back of
the rest of the mansion yeah but I don't
I and you say we want lots of words I
want to say I am as much the thing in
the back of the mansion I've never felt
that divide
oh no I agree with you I'm not saying
it's not you I obviously didn't make
that clear you're saying David is
different that's so yes since I the work
I'm gonna say the self is just a soul
and I believe it's just the subject of
consciousness and I of course I believe
in the subject of constant so I believe
in the secular soul now that it's
defined that way but it's not it's not
something that I'm not in touch with
it's just me Galen do you want to just
and explore perhaps a bit more about
about the brain and what we we know and
don't know about how we can have
concepts like consciousness generated by
physical masses is part of the problem
that we as humans just some facilities
just don't accept the idea or I haven't
been able to fully come to terms with
the idea that this physical matter can
create something that we call
consciousness because we can't see it in
the way that we can see a nerve twitch
or a muscle grow or shrink or diminish
or the blood flow around our body I
think so I think it's just that the
ordinary notion of matter has the
mistake has already been made because I
think far as i concerned consciousness
is just one form of matter and it's
actually what you get with some very
ordinary elements like carbon oxygen
nature and so on so matter is far far
more extraordinary than we think there
one way to put it is to say matter is
far more extraordinary than we think
and we're very hooked on this notion of
matter it's just the stuff you kick and
that's completely wrong I mean as
actually I mean look at physics I mean
physics just gets weirder every day and
so really it's there's a bad picture of
matter and once you get rid of the bad
petrm matter you can see that there is
no there's no deep difficulty we don't
understand it there's no deep difficulty
in the idea that consciousness just is
matter David you want to come in about
because believe me a lot of the work you
do as a filmmaker is trying to represent
hmm
visually or verbally concepts that are
not necessarily visual ones yes well
yeah I think that's I feel that's quite
important and it gets to something that
you said in it when you said it the
child has a sense of self and only later
do we have this more grandiose term now
obviously I agree with that but I I
think that the reason it comes later is
because what you're describing for my
view is the talking part of you when it
gets old enough to be able to conjure up
for itself using words what it thinks
this thing is but I think the child has
it long before the bit of it that
masters language can cobble together a
theory of what it is in other words
you're right we have to by the time we
can get to be undergraduates and I've
learnt all those long words which
impress her with which we impress
ourselves we then cobble together a
grandiose thing of what the soul is that
may or may not be the soul but what
you're describing is the product of the
talking bit of you the self interview
and I think it exists in us long before
the self comes together
it's explanation of it so I think the
child does have it I am NOT saying it
just is consciousness it might be but I
think it's the expression of
consciousness the way consciousness
works before you have the part of you
that lives and expresses itself through
the grammar of language okay well I just
I mean I've never found that my doctor
the best way to talk about the soul um
you've got aspirin wizard so soul and
consciousness could be
interchange of interchangeable and I
would say they can't fit for two reasons
one is that we can have consciousness
before we have a soul and it's not we
have little babies was one example but
many other animals non-human Andrews of
course her consciousness and have a
certain sense of self even which which
certainly it's not elaborated into the
idea of the soul but equally I think we
many people in the human tradition have
assumed that you can have a soul even
when you're not conscious for example
when you go to sleep at night your soul
doesn't die your soul carries on from
one moment to the next and in fact
you'll be emerge and take control over
it again or totally come to participate
it again
next next day but it didn't you know
it's not a new civil next morning so I
think the words are certainly not not
interchangeable and that's why I think
sometimes it's useful to try and use
imagery as a way of trying to get away
from trying to use words to talk about
it because words are the province of the
self mm-hmm and so you've got them self
trying to describe the soul and quite
naturally it does allow the job because
I think this up is quite happy to be
king of the roost and to deny that
anything else exists and I think there's
the possibility at least that it might
exist all I'm arguing for is to say that
I think it's a mistake to think that the
part of you that I would call self the
talking bit the bit that worries about
its overdraft is the entirety of the
entity which is you
I think the entity which is Galen is
that part of you but there's a lot else
and it may not be stuff that's so easy
to report on using language because it
was there before we had language and it
possibly doesn't use language itself and
it's certainly not logical and
computational we come up with answers
and which we couldn't get to buy any
more any computational means at all and
that's just the result of some
mathematical words that's just a fact
not all things can be computed that fell
out of girdle touring and chaitin's work
so how did we do it
Gailen can all things be ultimately the
subject of a chemical process mmm what
and all things to which David I mean
chemistry isn't amazing as matter but
also you know I don't want I don't have
the talking bit you see now I know what
you mean okay if the self is just the
conscious self and then it then that's
not all that I am but I would never want
to use the word self like that no I
don't do the stuff that just comes to
mind is is me and actually it's very the
stuff that just comes to one's mind is
very revealing of who you are but I just
don't want to say I don't want to split
linguistically between self and soul at
all why not well I just don't I don't
think there's a disunity there I mean
I'm sure I'm not in touch with myself in
many ways but that's still that listen
to that phrase I'm not in touch with
myself it's still me well I think I mean
we haven't actually brought religion
into this at all and I maybe there was
the tone well I mean I and I think we
will probably all agree that human self
would him spirituality Creed long
pre-existed organized religion actually
religion was was your terms of
johnny-come-lately and historic yes
indeed and that it actually it's been
it's been Paris it's a parasitical on
human consciousness um religion
institutional religion found fertile
ground in human spirituality but human
spirituality existed in its own right
and for very good reasons very much
earlier than that because it was a
driving force of the emergence of human
civilization um but of course I mean
recently of the church has decided that
they have the rights to the term soul
and very confused the whole issue but
one you say in soups is secular silver
then to come back I think it is
precisely by detaching itself from the
religious marriage which has become
attached to it more recently I mean do
you think this room for that that sort
of mean as Nick was saying we didn't
talk about that at the very start but
about whether there is room for a
secular definition of the soul that he
that will also be scientifically useful
I think they definitely I'm not sure how
much we agree and disagree I think as
the soul of the immortal soul from God I
personally don't believe in it like I
can't fit it into my view of the world
if other people do that's fine that's
their business but it doesn't work for
me but what I would say is I think a lot
of the things which are described in the
religious soul that it doesn't feel like
yours that it's possibly wiser than you
that it has thoughts which it seems to
have that come to you fully formed like
a gift I think all those things are true
but I don't think they come from God in
another realm
I think they come from the same physical
process which is you I just think the
process which is you know as I think
Galen is saying either got a lot more
mysterious and I come back to the self
which is that the bit of you that's
sitting there and the bit of me which is
pontificating and it I think we've
especially in science there's been a
tendency to write about the self as if
it was a genius and mother Teresa Walton
was in charge of everything I think
we're all the Ronald Reagan's of our own
brains where someone who's rather good
at giving speeches gets it has a lot of
other people working for him gets memos
and weeded out very convincingly it's
actually quite thick because I can't
claim that some of my best thoughts were
mine I didn't work them out it just came
fully formed I thought gee that's
fantastic so it wasn't myself which did
it was my entity it was me and I just
want to say let's I I personally need
warmth more vocabulary Rijn lines and I
need less just because I mean thoughts
no I agree they come from everywhere
share thoughts I mean I can have your
thoughts you can tell them to me yes but
I can't have your pens for example and
that's why I've in my more recent won't
come back again and again to sensation
as the primary and and most mysterious
quality of all of of consciousness
because it has all that is it has these
various strange characteristics which
really challenge explanation like the
fact that that is completely inalienable
the sensation of rent or the taste of an
anchovy I mean Kandra wants one of his
novels said in faults I mean thoughts
that to a penny we can we can throw them
around but when some did treads on my
toe
only I feel the pain and that's the
beginning of the idea of a personal self
and an individual self and breeding
ground for this extraordinary important
human characteristic of individual soul
food and I think I mean I'm great
individualist in that sense I think
individuality individualism has been
crucial to our successes as creatures
living on this world again and it's part
of the frustration in all of this sort
of debate for you that trying to come
back to evidence trying to come back to
demonstrate demonstrable repeatable
proof of some of these ideas I don't
think so I just I'm still puzzling with
that with the map here because when you
David say things like it didn't come
from me yeah that's that's me the self
yes you know if you think you have a
soul then it did come from user so yes
for my entity yes right it's like if
I've got a big mechanism oh sorry
right so I'm just saying why not expand
your notion of user subjective
experience
suggesting include the this what you're
now calling so I mean there's an
interesting thing here there's an
empirical difference between people who
feel that most of their thoughts just
come to them and I'm just like you in
that respect there are people who have
what this psychologist called Wagner
cause the emotion of authorship and/or
the emotion of ownership and there are
people in foster who say I really have
my thoughts and I did it aren't I good
and there well I think most people it
just happens it just comes and lots of
our language reveals this because we say
it struck me that or I realized that or
it came to me that and this is the truth
but I don't feel I'm not the thing and
well sometimes I do maybe I feel it's
coming to me from not me that's when I'm
being them yourself in your sense again
what are your relations relations don't
just come to you they don't just strike
you presumably you do take
responsibility for what you wish yeah
that's all the story but if I mean if
you who believe in free will actually
say well I've sound not entirely sure
this afternoon as the gentleman said
whether or not we've managed to touch
your soul but at least we come up with a
few more potential words beyond the to
self saw intuition subconscious and even
spirit so there's a lexicon to go away
with if nothing else for now thank you
all very much and thank you to our panel
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of arts
and ideas at iai TV
you